for those red tents for the Socialist
Party here kind of give you the story
the old saying is the issue is never the
issue the issue is always the revolution
so they see an energy that's built up
that's mad at something that's going to
throw off western civilization and they
say hey those are our
people all right James Lindsay here we
go again you were on my show just a few
weeks ago so I am completely uh jumping
over your intro here and I'm going to
start by throwing to a video that you
put up on Twitter from uh two days ago
at one of the protests in London let's
take a
[Music]
[Applause]
look yes
look at you walking through a Hamas
alley how about that yeah well the wrong
way um that was pretty wild right not
walking with a homas rally walking into
a Hally straight into literally right
down the middle of the Strand I was just
going to I had I had to go that way I
wasn't being defiant to be defiant I had
to go that way and they were in my way
so I just went the way I wanted to go do
you think it's a fair estimation for me
to call it a Hamas rally and not a pro
pales sign Rally or something like that
I do not make the distinction because I
don't see anyone there making the
distinction so I'm letting them answer
it for me yeah I would think that's
probably right it it was a very confused
rally um as well in a very opportunistic
situation every tube stop uh there was
red tent set up for the the Socialist
Workers Party of the UK handing out
propaganda saying that it's a communist
movement and I have a lot of it so I put
something on Twitter I'm not
exaggerating that literally this is you
know the Socialist inata or whatever
inata I guata yeah frata which means
soon I looked it up it means shaking off
an Arabic like a dog shaking off water
so they're going to shake off the
existing Society or in in the Middle
East they're going to shake off Israel
and so I would say that that's right
though and what was it 100 I heard 150
I've heard 100,000 people and it was it
was quite quite the energy what do you
make of this bizarre Alliance obviously
from an American perspective you've been
uncovering and unmasking the marxists
and the far-left lunatics and all of
this stuff you you've been doing this
for a long long time now now it seems to
have this connection with the islamists
uh which has given it some kind of hyper
fuel yeah well um there's there's a
number of things and we talked you know
the other day we can talk about it again
about the deeper intellectual currents
they share in common but for those red
tents for the Socialist Party here kind
of give you the story the old saying is
the issue is never the issue the issue
is always the revolution so they see an
energy that's built up that's mad at
something that's going to throw off
western civilization and they say hey
those are our people and that's that's
the simplest thing and opportunistically
they show up and they you know this is
really a communist thing and hanging out
communist propaganda I talked to a
number of Communists were very nice
people but seemed a bit confused um what
did when you talk to these people and
I'm not talking about the the actual
islamists who there but when you talk to
just like the Communist kid or whatever
that's there like what do they think
they are doing they are uh throwing off
years and years and years of of
Oppression of oppressive systems that
keep people down that you know whether
they're racist whether they're
xenophobic whether there's I guess
there's queers for Palestine so quer
phobic or transphobic or whatever phobic
that's buildings to throw people off in
Gaza right now turns out that they have
taken some of them down in in a you know
uncontrolled demolition right but but
but these Marxist kids that you're
talking I I say they're kids but it's
mostly in their 20s or something I mean
they're mostly they're mostly upper
middle class British people right the
accents were upper middle class British
accents pretty much across the board and
it was mostly young very young people
who you would expect to see over at the
London School of Economics probably they
matriculated over lots and lots and lots
of Irish uh somebody mentioned that they
were being flown in from Belfast and
then um older ladies with kind of you
know a middle class accent as well uh
would represent the Socialist but I
think they were there largely
opportunistically um the Muslims I think
are not going to be as friendly to their
Vision as as they might hope and it's
they're not going to see solidarity I
think that actually happened in one of
the countries in the Middle East they
paired up with the socialists they get
the Revolution and then the Muslims told
the Socialists you can choose Islam or
death and uh there's no socialism there
right I mean they just get ahead it a
little bit later in right I mean that
that seems to be it what do you did you
talk to any of the islamist did not um
they you know they they didn't seem very
interested in in conversation and like I
said I literally was just trying to go
down the street the other way to get to
well as it turns out the London School
of Economics is where we were headed to
go see it and see the upside down Globe
the world turned upside down is there
kind of symbolism there it's a socialist
institution um we were we were trying to
make our way over and see some of the
the darker sites of London uh but I
didn't speak with them now so look your
your an idea is guy you've been trying
to uncover a lot of this for a long time
and and you've done it quite well but
now that you're seeing it on the ground
and we're seeing it in all of these
other Western societies what are some of
the things we can do to reverse it I
mean that's what I've been asking
several of the guests so far I don't
know that anyone's had like the fully
right answer other than kind of expose
it and see what happen well there is I
mean it does start with Expose and
explain exposing and explaining are the
number one as far as a Marxist take over
there's an old saying that the marxis
feere is nothing more than exposure um
even more than death and so exposure
matters explaining what's going on and
and why it's going on matters but one
thing that the conservatives are very
bad at is parlaying that into the next
step of action as far as things go so
Bud Light that got exposed they exposed
themselves really and barass themselves
they get hit with a multi-billion dollar
you know boycott and then what happened
Bill Gates bought a bunch of their
stock wamp wamp like what happened at no
point was there a Senate Judiciary
Committee or oversight committee saying
calling these CEOs and saying what led
you to make this decision was it just
virtue signaling did do you really
believe in it did somebody have a
financial gun to your head and tell you
you have to because that's a very
interesting story and that passes the
buck up the chain and that's not
happening we're not taking the next
steps so we've got to do a lot more of
that the underground journalism expose
explain motivate get parents going
organized that all matters but what
they've also got to do again is take the
next step what's the next step step well
our main blockade in many cases people
are discovering is that the Republican
party is not as collaborative in
stopping woke as we would hope so it's
about time for people to start taking
over local Republican parties those are
achievable targets even in Connecticut
they're doing it which is like the most
law the Constitution states what's going
on what's going on they are organizing
and he doesn't take very many numbers
they've taken over Greenwich which is
like a leftist Bastion and they organize
and they realize that at meetings where
say the Republican party chair for the
township or District or County or
whatever that not very many people show
up to the meetings where those chairs
and those other officials are elected so
they're getting a few dozen or maybe a
few score people together showing up to
the meeting and voting their people in
then guess what now they have a lever
over the state RNC because they have
somebody that's a seat at the table and
this is a replicable model that can
happen everywhere so you can start
taking back power over the Republican
Party locally to get the Rhinos out to
get these kind of complicit or fearful
or clueless or feckless or corrupt
politicians out of these seats and start
putting in people who want to put a stop
to this stuff who who will make the
policy differences who will be the sand
and the gears on the committee that
makes it so they the left doesn't just
have a free March through the
institutions even further and it's
working where people are doing it let's
back up for a second because one of the
things that I'm noticing and I see this
in the video that you posted from from
what we're seeing now at college campus
is the way they're weaponizing our
freedoms against us the way they're
using Free Speech against us the same
people who last year were afraid of
microaggressions and if you know scary
James Lindsay showed up to campus are
now calling for you know from The River
To The Sea palestin will be free uh
which is coded genocide can you talk a
little bit about how they use how they
weaponize our freedoms against us and
then how they use language in a very
bizarre way so that the people who
should be defending Free Speech guys
like us are also trying to expose how
they're using Free Speech against us
yeah well I mean that's that's how they
operate right but just to be real clear
about the the slogan from The River To
The Sea Palestine will be free of what
juice right yeah it will be free of
juice that's that's what what it is it's
it's a call call for genocides if you
read the Hamas Charter it's not
ambiguous on what it's calling for and
I've heard that the Arabic is slightly
different it's from water to water
Palestine will be Muslim which tells you
something a little bit different uh does
it
well it it answers the question free of
what free of what and so it it answers
that question so let's not be ambiguous
about what they're calling for and then
of course some people were unhappy with
this so what do they reply with academic
freedom Free Speech this is a free
speech institution we had you know oh
all of a sudden the same people who for
years now have been trying to silence
everybody the same people who were
firing people over I don't remember I
don't know if you remember the the the
communications Professor who was
explaining that in China there a word
for you can't remember the word which
I'll say cuz it's Chinese
isaaa well you can hear what it sounds
like so they thought well somebody might
think he's trying to say a racial slur
so they got him fired yeah they were
that stupidly sensitive to free speech
uh being you know a tool of Oppression
you know mere months ago actually in
fact probably until October 6th and then
the second they started running their
mouths and as they would call it
accountability and consequences started
to come their way no no no no no we need
our Free Speech we need free speech and
of course what they mean by free speech
is there's no accountability for them
but there will be accountability for
everybody else so what do we do with
that as the Defenders of free speech
what do we do with that knowing what
they are doing well the answer is we saw
the answer in the 1960s in the south at
the lunch counters you speak freely and
then you take the consequences and then
you make a lot of noise about the
consequences people have got to stop
being afraid of the consequences they've
got to stop being afraid of making a
sacrifice I was writing over here the
best talk I've heard at the conference
so far was a cabbie well no that's not
true Jordan spoke this morning it was
beautiful but besides Jordan yeah was
the cabbie on the on the right over here
from downtown last night and he's just
talking and he you know he he's he's
dialed in his eyes are open he's tuned
in but he's
very Resolute in saying that we we we
we've just got to tell the truth we've
just got to be willing to to he said
what what brought it up is what is that
he said we're caught in a dilemma where
people are too afraid to lose their
living their means of making a living so
they're willing to give up their freedom
not realizing what that means a step
down the track and so frog in a pot
thing you yeah so you've got to be
willing to to take the risk of losing
something you might not lose it if you
take the is a very we could go we do a
whole Jordan hour right now if we wanted
to you know he's talking about Cain and
Abel who does that a lot and he's said
well you know Cain was making an
insufficient sacrifice Abel's giving the
best fat God Smiles upon Him Kane's
pissed off kills him and you know
instead of making a better sacrifice if
you're not willing to make a sacrifice
we're not going to win this so people
have what what do we do we tell the
truth boldly but not rashly then get to
your Greek virtues or whatever and don't
be afraid of the consequences and when
there are consequences we point out the
Injustice the people that went to the
lunch counters in the 1960s sat at the
lunch counter and they said serveice
lunch if you Ser us lunch we leave they
weren't wor sitting in and occupying
we're not occupying your restaurant
service lunch like anybody else and them
we'll go but if you don't we're going to
sit here till you do right and they
waited and people wouldn't and then they
get yelled at and they got hit and then
the cops come drag them out looks real
bad turns out this works and when we are
being unjustly persecuted this way this
is the attitude we actually have to take
one thing that you and I have both gone
through over the last couple years is
that you you are you still an atheist
you consider well I'm alleged I spent a
lot of time with Charlie Kirk so I have
to say agnostic fair enough Charlie's
working on me he but but you were that's
what Char used to say to me also but but
basically you were you I don't want to
put words in your that but you were a
very well-known let's say liberal
atheist who has now found mostly common
cause with say more believing
conservatives something like that we've
talked about it a bunch before but does
that still when you wake up every
morning seem a little bizarre to you or
or does it now just seem very obvious I
mean I seems very obvious obious I think
there was the bizarre phase but it
wasn't I don't think it took very long
um maybe most of 2019 a little of 20 and
what does that say about the The Atheist
liberals then I suppose because I think
people understand what it says about the
the conservative religious people who
have become I have not looking back on
that I've not found that to be a very
welcoming group of people a very kind
group of people a group of people who
have um a vision for something that
makes you know you want to get out of
bed in the
morning kind of a a little bit of a
cesspool there are wonderful people here
and there within it and then there are
awful people but that's true of
everything but uh it there's a there's
there's a lack of I don't know General
positivity maybe faith is the word that
um it you know looking back it's a bit
of a
shame yeah it is a damn shame because it
didn't have to be this way and I think
that that's when so many of us were
screaming about like come on the BRS
like you don't have to do this but they
all just kind of committed har Kari yeah
well you know they they had to find some
way to to inject meaning and
and humanism is an interesting
phenomenon a lot of them attach
themselves oh I'm a you know secular
humanist or liberal humanist or whatever
well you know you track back turns out
KL marks called his philosophy humanism
he didn't call it Marxism he was KL Marx
that would have been a little weird
right he called it too Mone he said his
goal was to humanize the world through
the work of man that's liberated from
labor and private property and so to
make the world more and more a human
place in befitting humans and then make
humans as the object of our own work
more human and uh
that's not a good path it's just it's
it's rooted in critique it's rooted in
negativity I look back at the new
atheist movement and I think honestly
you know we talk about critical race
Theory or critical gender Theory or
whatever critical theory you want it's
very much critical religion Theory it's
very if you go back and you read the the
first page of uh Marx's critique of
hegel's philosophy of right which sounds
obscure but that's the very famous
religion is the Opia of the masses page
it's just one page it's the very first
page of this you know 300 and some odd
page book that nobody wants to read it
feels like that whole movement and you
can see that it's like the seeds of all
the wrong direction are are kind of tied
up within that that might have been the
first time we ever met in person was at
that Reon rally and when I spoke at I
think this was that probably 2015
something it was 15 yeah yeah and I
spoke at the mall there and I remember
saying in my speech I was like guys do
you see what's happening here and I
think I was probably the only person
doing it I'm not saying that to Pat
myself on the back but I was I could see
all of the wrongness and unfortunately I
guess I became right but let me end with
this because you mentioned jokingly as
we walked in he said everybody's talking
about a story in there right like that's
the idea and this is the arc pamphlet
obviously as you guys can see it says a
better story so what is the better story
I mean you're particularly good at
laying out the the critiques of the
history for the bad story but what what
is our better story well I mean just to
listen to Jordan of course he laid it
out so so Jordan Le um which I think
should just be an adjective at this
point really should be and I think you
just coined it yeah but it's true but he
he talked about how uh the path to
abundance and prosperity and the as he
calls it as in very Jordan Le said the
adventure of your life yeah you know you
all of a sudden felt like you're back on
the road with them and you hear that the
adventure of your lifetime is discovered
through taking responsibility within
your own sphere of Life cleaning your
room so to speak but getting your own
life in order then building a family and
having it ordered and then letting order
spread outward where taking
responsibility gets you out of this he
said infantile state where all of your
needs are met like a child but you have
no liberty and you get to go on the
adventure of your life through taking
personal and then family and then
community and then even National
responsibility civic responsibility um
so that he said as we can we have to in
a sense choose whether we're going to
tilt the world toward heaven or tilt the
world toward hell and tilt the world
uphill or tilt the world downhill and
how do we do that and he said it so the
better story is if you take
responsibility ility in your life and
try to be a proactive Builder ordered
builder of your life there's a better
story for all of us on the other side of
that decision and I think that I have to
concur completely with that analysis I
mean not that Jordan's wrong a lot but
uh that's I've been preaching a lot of
the same thing lately I found it
ironically perhaps you'll enjoy this one
of my favorite words is a different RW
not responsibility but repent and I I
don't technically believe in God so what
do I mean by that but say you got caught
up in this woke stuff a lot of people
did or you got caught up in Co hysteria
a lot of people did where you got caught
up in pick your favorite politician
doesn't have to be Trump dang inome a
lot of people
did you have to get inside yourself and
say I messed up it's not just well a lot
of people messed up it doesn't matter
you have to get inside yourself and say
I messed up and you got to get right in
your
conscience with where you were and then
take responsibility for the mistakes you
made and the direction you want to go in
the future and I I call people to repent
all the time repent of the woke repent
of your participation look at what's
happening in the world right now look
what they're cheering for you know glory
to the martyrs on the side of Columbia
University look what they're cheering
for repent and take responsibility I
think and then there's a better story
your life gets better just like walking
Upstream up through the thing where he
started there if you just live your life
in truth not I wasn't being glib I
wasn't try trying to provoke I was
genuinely going that way and I wasn't
going to let them deter me if you just
live that way what I found is 49 out of
50 times you got to burn a little
corruption out of your life first sure
but 49 out of 50 times your life gets
better one time something bad happens
and so what and 49 out of 50 times it
gets better it's just this constant
building when you're willing to to get
straight on the truth and just go the
direction that you need to go without
worrying too much about what's going on
around you James I suspect that
literally and metaphorically we will
continue to walk through gamas yeah what
say look forward to it actually if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell